[Música]
ricas café o el castor cibernética como
también le conocemos de cariño los
saluda paloma martínez desde nuestros
estudios aquí en la ciudad de montreal
les damos la bienvenida a todos aquellos
que nos acompañan por facebook live por
youtube live o por cualquier otro medio
en nuestro sitio internet www.dgt.es
aquí en el estudio estamos leonora
gimeno como están
[Música]
todo el mundo
mucho gusto que estén con nosotros como
siempre en los viernes que es la cita
semanal del equipo latinoamericano de
radio canadá internacional
latinoamericano y hoy estuvimos
conversando en la oficina de esto porque
por segundo año consecutivo
depende del don en realidad claro este
es el primer año oficial
de montreal encontramos la manera
citación de la municipalidad de monte
del mes que estuvimos ahí sin poder
saber muy por qué no es la primera vez
que hay festejos de la comunidad hispana
exacto pero lo que descubriste vos
finalmente paloma es un sitio del
gobierno donde el gobierno canadiense a
nivel federal claro dictaminó que el mes
de octubre a partir del 2018 es el mes
de la herencia latinoamericana en todo
canadá en todo el canadá
la confusión un poco de la conversación
era que también hay mes de la herencia
hispana hay mes de la herencia hispana
latina entonces hay hay muchos eventos
de esa naturaleza pero esta es la
primera vez aquí en montreal y en canadá
también desde el año pasado digo que se
festeja el mes de la herencia
latinoamericana y eso ya queda como fijo
está por ley canadienses por parlament
por el parlamento canadiense y lo
interesante es que esta semana
justamente vas a resaltar un reportaje
que tiene que ver con la contribución de
los latinos canadienses a la economía
cultura a la sociedad sistema
exactamente
ese fue el lanzamiento hace poco tiempo
contó con la participación de valor y
plante que es la alcaldesa de montreal
entonces hay todo hay un grupo
interesante festejando aquí en montreal
es importante porque la comunidad
latinoamericana en todo el canadá hace
mucho tiempo que está instalada acá
digamos que ha habido varias olas de
inmigración de refugio latinoamericano
en el canadá desde hace 40 años por lo
menos vivimos estamos hablando que
empezaron a llegar más sobre todo con el
golpe de estado en chile
muchísimos chilenos llegaron a canadá
luego siguieron salvadoreños por la
guerra que había en el américa central
argentinos y uruguayos en fin del cono
sur de centroamericano después empezó y
ya una ola más económica y ahí pues hoy
en día estamos hablando que montreal la
ciudad de montreal cuenta con 135 mil
ciudadanos canadienses montreal ens es
de origen latinoamericano entonces hasta
no hace mucho tiempo 23 años
hablando tal vez de 100.000 entonces hay
un crecimiento muy fuerte que es
importante que se está dando y creo que
esto se refleja en la creación de este
mes de la herencia latinoamericana en
canadá porque este crecimiento se da de
este a oeste y de norte a sur
por todo el país en muchos latinos de
origen latinos canadienses que están
viviendo en el lejano norte canadiense
cada vez más en el yukón en el nunavut
en los territorios del noroeste hay que
tener coraje desde ya emigrar no es
fácil para que eduque no lo han hecho la
experiencia eliminación no es fácil
emigrar a un lugar te diría que casi
casi en el límite de lo inhóspito es
debe ser complicado
latinoamérica nos encontramos allá
valientes no pasarnos de una semana dos
semanas lo mismo es lo mismo que estar
ahí viviendo a mí creo que lo que
molestaría si yo tengo una
un internet de muy alta velocidad
no me molestaría pasar un tiempo allá lo
están haciendo lo están haciendo me
acuerdo perfectamente hace años había
una señora de origen mexicano en el psuv
con que habíamos ido una vez
no me acuerdo exactamente el año esa
señora mexicana llegó no sé de dónde y
puso un restaurante mexicano león xiii
es un éxito por eso te digo se puede
vivir hay que abrigarse bien hay que
abrigarse nuestro clima no ya empezamos
abrigarnos sí bueno vamos a hablar de
ser un tránsito y tomás porque es una de
las cosas insólitas de esta semana y
otra cosa insólita es que leonardo en su
crónica tecnológica esta semana nos
habla de carne que ustedes no entienden
ciencia y tecnología que no tiene que
ver con la ciencia porque es un estudio
masivo de otros estudios preliminares
sobre el consumo de carnes rojas y
carnes procesadas
que dice que en realidad seguir comiendo
lo que uno como hasta ahora no haría mal
que contradice a bueno un montón de
otros estudios que dicen absolutamente
lo contrario que es dañino que puede
causar problemas coronarios problemas de
cáncer por ejemplo
más adelante pero vamos han como paloma
de que vas a hablar tú tema yo voy a
hablarles de un beisbolista de béisbol y
de los volvió un poquito más adelante
pero antes quiero presentarles una
invitada que tenemos por teleconferencia
por skype se llama julia iriarte y ella
vive en la ciudad de vancouver
justamente que tal julia y julia mucho
gusto que estés con nosotros
julia cineasta y presentó recientemente
un documental que se llama sádicas
garden o el jardín de sádica
la historia de refugio de empatía
entonces quisimos invitarla para que nos
cuente un poco por qué se interesó en
esta temática pero antes de entrar de
lleno en la temática menos un poquito de
usted julia porque usted nació en buenos
aires o de nación argentina estudio en
buenos aires dyn después hizo un diploma
que en vancouver sobre multimedia si
tengo en tengo entendido pero cuéntenos
un poquito y sé cómo se describiría
usted
le cuento un poco mi historia como
previamente a la universidad cine en
argentina y empecé a trabajar
rápidamente después de estudiar en la
universidad del cine en argentina en
algunas películas y comerciales salud y
algunas películas internacionales que me
llevaron a conocer gente de canadá y
terminé viviendo en canadá la película
que hizo un poco que termine acá fue
siete años en el tíbet con la de sonia
cano y brad pitt en el 97 se filmó en
argentina y yo trabajé en esa película y
terminé poniéndome de novia con un
colombiano canadiense y con la próxima
en la próxima entonces sí entonces
con un colombiano canadiense colombiano
canadiense también
he trabajado en filmación internacional
en películas grandes y se mudó argentina
conmigo y después al anillo nos
decidimos venir a vancouver y probar a
kayak y quedé nomás varada en parís
[Risas]
porque le interesó hablar de volvamos
entonces a la película que estás
presentando ahora que tengo entendido su
primer largometraje documental por lo
que entiendo
es un mediometraje si eso 30 minutos más
o menos sí y yo trabajé en otros
documentales
en la parte de edición y produje un
documental hace tiempo para webs cause
live que es un grupo de mujeres abogadas
que luchan por los derechos de las
mujeres en canadá
pero fue la intención de ese documental
el que lo hice hace mucho tiempo
así que decir es la primera vez que
dirijo junto a mí a mi amigo chat
calloway con lo que dirigimos juntas o
dirigimos y cómo producimos juntas
sádica garde estáticas garden el jardín
de sádica
y la idea comenzó porque cuando fue la
crisis de siria
la verdad que me afecta nos afectó a
todos mucho sobre todo lo que se veía en
los medios de comunicación y me acerqué
a un grupo de latinoamericanos los
abuelos que se hicieron llamar a vos se
hacen llamar abuelo porque son gente que
es general son abuelos
latinoamericanos políticos exiliados
políticos en su momento la mayoría de la
época de pinochet que se vinieron de
chile en los 70 73 en 1973 y me junté
con ellos para tratar de ayudar a en
ésta a ver como que se podía hacer para
ayudar a la en la crisis de desidia y
ver si ellos tenían ya tenían un grupo
formado yo conocía a uno de los miembros
que estaban vinculados con mosaic es un
organismo
una organización de inmigración acá en
canadá en vancouver y me acerqué a
víctor porter que yo ya lo conocía
previamente y le dije qué puedo hacer
para ayudar y muy plata no tenía pero sí
tenía conocimiento para poder hacer algo
y se me ocurrió hacer un pequeño vídeo
tipo go fans para juntar plata y el
videito que hicimos tuvo mucho éxito él
juntó bastante plata para poder traer
una familia el resto de la familia siria
que van a ver en este en mi documental
los abuelos y tres de los a
de los hermanos de xavi de los miembros
si te contara eso entonces la historia
de esta familia es una familia que salió
de siria debido a la guerra que se está
viviendo en esa región del mundo se
fueron tengo entendido al líbano y
después a partir del líbano fue que
vinieron a canadá y les grupo de abuelos
fue el grupo que apadrinó a la familia
para que pudieran llegar como refugiados
a canadá y bueno eso representaba claro
muchos gastos porque cuando uno apadrina
a alguien pues significa que uno es
responsable financieramente de esa
cierta cantidad de tiempo en el marco
del programa de crudo cuando inició
justamente junto con naciones unidas del
programa para traer 25 mil sirios y que
era como también una cuestión del
gobierno pero también se daba entrada a
lo privado justamente para poder
apadrinar a familias sirias
ss en el marco de ese programa
lo hicieron en realidad ellos estuvieron
fueron más héroes todavía pueblo y se
empezaron el tema ellos se juntaron y
decidieron hard en live fue la época de
harper que en realidad se juntaron el
descubrir marcar no estaba de acuerdo en
traer familias entonces ellos dijeron lo
vamos a hacer privado de manera privada
y se limitaron entre todos y esto es lo
que lo más interesante que
tuvieron que tocar muchas puertas y
hacer un bastante el proceso lo
empezaron antes de trigo y después vino
el gobierno de todos y facilitó que esto
suceda facilitó que es el proceso
termine de ser cumplido y ahí
hoy que pudieron traer la primera parte
de la familia que es si es sádica y sus
hijos tienen muchos hijos
son eran son ocho y ocho hijos y ella y
el marido y bueno en todos acá todos
llegaron tanto o se acaba viven en
richmond ahí le estamos viendo sádica y
les estás si tienen la verdad que tiene
son
gente que está haciendo muy bien y están
trabajando muy duro para poder
tener una buena vida
y poder estudiar aprender el idioma
pensar que ellos vinieron acá y no
sabían nada ni el alfabeto tenían o sea
cuando llegaron cuando llegaron en el
2016 llegaron a canadá en el 2016 en qué
consiste ese apadrinamiento si podemos
decirlo así de esa manera es que a qué
se comprometen por ejemplo los abuelos
los abuelos bueno
la cantidad de trabajo que hacen por
esta familia y todavía ellos tienen un
compromiso creo que es por tres años
primero que final financieramente tiene
que juntar x cantidad d
de dinero
el familiar y después pero ellos se
hicieron todo desde conseguirle social
your number a esta casa o sea los
ayudaron en todo y todavía lo siguen
ayudando es increíble ya ya
ya terminaron su responsabilidad como
grupo de sponsor pero si tienen dos
amistades exacto ya no pueden poner
digamos un límite de decir bueno
legalmente hasta acá llegamos porque ya
hay un vínculo que es a paso para más
allá y jackson como familia de ellos
cuando se presenta el documental donde
se lo puede ver
bueno el documental lo mostraron un par
de seseña y en distintas cátedras
solamente dos veces
no van a salir va a estar en el festival
mena se llama el middle east festival
eso va a ser en dos semanas n militar
vancouver y también se puede ver online
porque los que nos dieron digamos los
que nos dieron la plata para hacer el
documental fue telus theory hyde
y ellos tienen un canal online que se
llama optic tv y otro canal en youtube
de telus y ahí está ya online está
sádicas cárdenas y que la gente lo puede
ver online ya está vi digamos lo vamos a
poner en la página de nuestro sitio
internet el vínculo para que pueda la
gente ir a mirar a mirarlo sobre toda la
gente que nos que no se está siguiendo
desde américa latina porque tenemos
mucho público en américa latina entonces
la gente que no podrá digamos ir a las
presentaciones en vancouver o en otras
regiones de canadá donde se pueda
presentar el documental lo podrán ver a
través de la página internet de radio
canadá internacional yo quería
preguntarle julia que aprendió de la
experiencia de realizar este documental
con que se quedó usted
yo conocí gente increíble la gente de
abuelos es la verdadera gente que ha
hecho realmente son gente que como estos
mismos fueron exiliados políticos en la
época de pinochet
decidieron devolver a la sociedad lo que
les fue dado a ellos la mano que le fue
dada a ellos y son gente extraordinaria
lo que hacen cotidianamente por devolver
y por dar a la sociedad es increíble e
impagable aprendí mucho de ellos
será abierto y darnos cuenta de que al
final del día no importa la religión ni
el país de donde vengamos somos todos
seres humanos sí y de eso trata el
documental de humanizar digamos a esta
gente
y mostrar un poco que son que somos que
al final del día todos queremos lo mismo
queremos vivir en paz darle a nuestros
hijos la posibilidad de tener una vida y
una educación
y eso no y devolver devolver lo que nos
ha dado lo que se nos dio a nosotros de
tener la suerte de vivir en una sociedad
como canadá donde
no hay respeto y no hay tanta
discriminación como en otros países y
hay seguridad y hay digamos los human
rigths los derechos humanos básicos
están más que cubiertos tenemos la
suerte de vivir en uno de los pocos
países del mundo donde se respeta
a las mujeres
a los a la gente que es gay
entre las distintas culturas a las
distintas religiones y las minorías a
las minorías exactamente exactamente el
día
y eso más que nada ha aprendido de la
gente como les dije los verdaderos
héroes son estas este grupo de sponsor
que sacrificó un montón de su tiempo su
dinero propio porque pusieron plata de
ellos de su bolsillo hay gente que no es
rica para nada hay gente que trabajó
toda su vida muy duro para poder tener
una buena vida y tienen sus propios
hijos y nietos y sin embargo pusieron de
su bolsillo para poder hacer una
diferencia en la vida de otras personas
que son de otra cultura y otra religión
completamente diferente a la de ellos
porque
no tienen ningún tipo de deber de haber
hecho lo que hicieron y sin embargo al
día a día siguen aportando para hacer la
diferencia y ayudar a esta gente
julia iriarte muchas gracias por haber
conversado con nosotros por haber
aceptado esta entrevista para radio
canadá internacional en directo desde
vancouver le deseamos mucha suerte en la
difusión en la máxima difusión posible
de este documental y en todos los
proyectos se vengan así que muchas
gracias julia gracias a ustedes por
invitarme y por darme la oportunidad de
contar la historia
gracias pues un gusto conversar con
alguien así que tiene tantos proyectos
así que bueno si no hay un proyecto tan
lindo un proyecto donde uno siente que
el otro día escuchaba a alguien que
decía
este dicho que es
es mucho más sentido cuando alguien da
cuando el que no tiene edad que el que
le sobra
no es cierto o sea es bien recibido todo
lo que se da pero cuando uno no tiene
encima ese gesto de poder de la gente
que no conoce gente de otra cultura
gente que supongo que esta persona estas
personas los abuelos no dan el peso
nunca en realizar esto y ahora es un
sueño hecho realidad no estar ayudando a
alguien porque le falte porque tuvieron
la sensación de la necesidad de ese tipo
de ayuda y sino me estuve acordando al
escucharla hablar a julia de un
reportaje que hicimos también en hace
poco nosotros donde los nietos de esos
abuelos o los hijos de esos abuelos hoy
refugiados tomaron la posta solidaria
también de sus padres y están trabajando
acogiendo a refugiados de américa
central entonces me pareció muy
interesante el punto que destacó julio
en esta entrevista es decir los respetos
a los derechos humanos que hay aquí
las minorías entonces eso creo que vale
la pena destacar los problemas de
respeto a las mujeres y sabemos las el
feminicidio esa peste que está
ocurriendo en todo el mundo
hay una diferencia tenemos saludos y
manfred echeverría saludos amigos desde
el convulsionado ecuador dice nelson
contreras rincón buenas tardes saludos
desde barranquilla colombia miriam
alarcón hola que lindo verlos otra vez
gustavo lucas saludos desde melo cerro
largo uruguay efemérides para leonardo 4
octubre día del tamal
alan y malditos pobrecitos lo comemos
hacia luis balderas saludos desde san
antonio en chile dice el 4 de octubre
1917 nació en chile la famosa
folclorista violeta parda la cara más
preferido
967 gracias a la vida que me ha dado
tanto una de sus grandes
villalobos dice saludos de costa rica
pura vida qué lindo con sedesa rodríguez
charlize saludos desde bogotá buenos
temas y producción dice leónidas todos
santos nascimento
nos viene participando leónidas a
leónidas y j
lévesque dice saludos desde course pero
vivimos en ritmos key
que nos diga dónde queda donde queda
corto y yo le quería decir a manfred 10
en realidad a cualquiera que nos está
escuchando que por favor se comuniquen
con nosotros a través de vídeos de fotos
justamente manfred nos decía la
convulsionada ecuador es verdad entonces
queremos saber qué pasa en sus lugares
de origen y ustedes son nuestra
comunicación con esos lugares también
entonces si tienen algún vídeo
alguna foto que nos quieran enviar para
contarnos lo que está sucediendo la
sacan a la foto que filmen ellos meta
que saquen la foto que nos le envíen y
así podemos ir viendo lo que está
sucediendo en sus lugares de oriente
así que manfred cuéntanos también qué
está pasando con ecuador y bueno tenemos
un vídeo que me encanta presentar porque
elevado les explica también la
modificación de radio canadá internación
[Música]
queremos entonces el videito de la
aplicación porque esa aplicación cada
vez hay más gente que le está bajando a
partir de nuestro sitio internet
a partir del sitio internet se van hasta
las tiendas donde se ven dónde se pueden
encontrar la aplicación como tal
entonces ustedes van al sitio de
internet de radio canal internacional
abajo a la derecha está
la pequeña publicidad que manda a los
lugares oficiales para bajar la
aplicación la aplicación está en las
cinco lenguas en las que trabaja un
radio canal internacional les
recomendamos que bajen la española si
tienen otro lengua bajen la pero el
español y funciona súper bien es mucho
más rápida que el sitio de internet está
todo condensado uno puede guardar cosas
para hablar las después uno si tiene
problemas como yo para leer de cerca en
vez de sacarme los lentes como para dar
los mensajes de facebook lo podría hacer
directamente agrandando la tipografía
así que recomendados están los dígitos
es para los vigilantes y para los que
tienen problemas también un programa de
vista seguro realidad tengo lente de 13
años y que no eterno bueno así que eso
es vayan hagan clic en donde corresponde
que es en la publicidad ahí vas directo
y el vínculo iba a decir link al vínculo
para ir a bajar la aplicación en español
y les recordamos entonces nuestro sitio
internet www.bcn.cat y van a encontrar
entonces toda la información referente a
esta aplicación y a todas las cosas
maravillosas que hacemos en radio canadá
somos muy humildes y bueno pasemos a
esta semana dijimos que esta semana
habíamos sucedido cosas y no
insólitas entre nos vamos a mostrar
llegó el invierno eso nos hablaste tú de
eso llegó el invierno y estamos apenas
es que todavía orientamos no estamos en
invierno no el otoño y eso es parte de
lo que venimos hablando todo este tiempo
de las consecuencias del cambio
climático el recalentamiento del planeta
y si uno ve lo que pasó aquí en canadá y
fue la semana pasada cayó un metro de
nieve que se concentró sobre todo en la
provincia de alberta
calgary edmonton y se fue corriendo para
saskatchewan entonces ella decía que iba
a correrse un poco más también hacia
otras provincias ustedes pueden estar
viendo esto parece el mes de diciembre
enero no bueno en todo caso entonces
kayo es es tanta tanta nieve que hubo
como 170 choques de autos sin que
hubiese fue despacio fue uno detrás de
otro porque los autos resbalaban
entonces no hubo que lamentar víctimas
pero imaginen ustedes que caiga un metro
de nieve en pleno octubre para la gente
que no sabe los que nos están viendo
fuera de canadá en canadá hay una ley
que
obliga a la gente a cambiar los
neumáticos de los carros a partir de
creo que este año es anti siembre no
bien en realidad el 15 de diciembre pero
me parece que este año es antes porque
como consecuencia del cambio climático
las tormentas de nieve se dan mucho
antes entonces necesariamente hay que
ser precavido y poder conducir con
seguridad para esto entonces es
obligatorio cambiar las ruedas de los
autos en este caso hay ruedas para
invierno que tienen tacos más altos
salidas para el hielo para los costados
es una cuestión técnica muy específica
como cuando nosotros tenemos las botas y
tenemos que comprar esos excesos y ritó
lo que no le pone clavos es caro vivir
en un país eso no lo puede hacer está
todo preparado para el invierno o sea
acá no sé para los señores cuando hay
una tormenta de un metro y medio de
nieve nos separan yo he visto en
argentina me gustaba en argentina caían
dos centímetros nivel y dos veces en mi
ciudad dos centímetros y separaba la
ciudad bueno si la carga a kaká en
cuarenta centímetros dentro de dos días
cuarenta más y todos seguimos dando a
trabajar los chicos la escuela o sea no
para porque está preparado para eso
porque todo tiene que ver con esa parte
injustamente
esto pasó del otro lado de canadá donde
cayó de manera imprevista y nadie estaba
preparado y lo que yo quiero confesarles
es que yo no encontré un vídeo de esta
nevada lo que estábamos viendo y eso me
hizo comprobar que hace tiempo que las
nevadas están comenzando con
anticipación en un vídeo de hace cinco
años y lo que explicaban es que
justamente a partir de esa época ya era
un reportaje de civis y que explicaban
que efectivamente a partir de ciertos
años cinco años en particular
las nevadas llegaban antes que
normalmente entonces tenemos es una
tendencia que se está repitiendo
anualmente y en contra este video que lo
muestra que en esa época también estuvo
nevando en ese año también estuvo
nevando con anticipación antes más
temprano está llegando más temprano y
está durando más tiempo como que el
verano se está achicando de nuevo no lo
sé no lo sentí no lo escuché en el año
pasado en lo peor del invierno formas de
diciembre que no estamos acostumbrados
nosotros sí eso en diciembre del año
pasado hubieron dos semanas de -30 de
bueno entre otras
miriam alarcón dice saber que hay otras
realidades y posibilidades está muy
bueno argentina está mal y hay mucha
pobreza y femicidios lindo ver que hay
solo solidaridad en el mundo gracias por
el contenido del programa
a miriam que nos sigue eso también
gracias a argentina muy bien sí y otra
cosa que está sucediendo que comenzó ya
hace un tiempo en este en este país es
la campaña electoral
estamos siguiendo la campaña electoral
de hecho la semana próxima les vamos a
estar presentando dos entrevistas con
dos candidatos uno del partido verde y
uno del partido liberal que son latinos
que están participando en esta campaña
federal para elegir un nuevo gobierno en
el país y entre otras cosas estuvo tuvo
lugar el debate el primer debate en
francés
hay dos debates en francés y dos debates
en inglés y este es el primer debate en
francés y bueno los cuatro candidatos
más me llamaron estuvieron los cuatro
candidatos como era además en quebec y
va dirigido sobre todo a los
quebequenses y en francés entonces en
ese sentido participaron los cuatro que
vamos a nombrar los que se están crudos
que se les es el liberal el conservador
también que lo estamos viendo ahí
andrews y también estuvo el líder del
bloque quebequense que es un partido
independentista a nivel federal que se
presenta en estas elecciones y estuvo
liderado por françois blanco estamos
viendo
y también participó el neo demócrata
jack meeting que estuvieron en los
cuatro los que no participaron fue del
partido verde elisa de elisabeth porque
además creo que no habla francés
se habla un poco para un debate la
decisión de tve que es el de la red de
televisión que lo presentó es que ni ni
elizabeth may ni maxinver ni que eso
represente haber sentido de parte de
población popular no estarían
presentándose porque no tienen ninguna
cantidad de candidatos y pro diputados
tiene candidatos del partido que no
tiene ningún diputado elegido entonces
por eso decidieron que no que no se
presentaban ellos dos pero entonces ese
debate yo no era como lo resumiría este
debate fue un debate rápidamente
hablando fue un debate donde se
abordaron temas un poco yo podría tan
conflictivos pero que en una campaña
electoral tal vez toman otra dimensión
por ejemplo discutir sobre el aborto fue
ese tema fue el primer tema y ahí
para ti no ser del partido conservador
fue una patinada al estilo del pato
donald visto porque no quiere dar
manifestar su posición a diferencia de
todo a diferencia del debate tampoco
dijo yo soy
brody nastia no y no
católico dijo y no voy a durante el
gobierno si somos gobierno no va a haber
ningún cambio
[Música]
yo creo que lo que no entiendo
personalmente es cuál es el problema en
decir su posición si de todas maneras él
ya lo dijo anteriormente no vamos a
tocar esa ley que ya fue aprobada por el
parlamento canadiense desde hace
muchísimos años donde acá el aborto está
despenalizado ya no puede ser el
problema pueden elegir cuál es el
problema cuál es ese yo no entiendo a lo
mejor él tiene miedo de decir su
posición aunque finalmente la dijo bueno
hay patinó bastante digo bueno también
un poquito crudo estuvo flojo y era de
esperar en el tema medioambiental con el
acueducto famoso que él quiere construir
a toda costa cuando hay una oposición es
grande
de alberta y columbia británica donde
hay
posición de los verdes de los grupos
medioambientalistas y de la malla
también de las primeras naciones hay
para ti no un poco pero viendo el
análisis el análisis que hizo chantal
ver que es una gran analista que yo la
sigo siempre entonces hace análisis
interesantes
finalmente ya dijo el gran perdedor fue
el partido conservador en esta selección
entonces dijo cuanto antes se vaya de
quebec mejor porque acá no va a tener
mucho espacio para ganar
si ya dice joel díaz ya digo ya me
imagino que le están diciendo sus
consejeros que se vaya indirectamente a
ontario porque ahí va a estar la batalla
va se va a dar en ontario y también para
crudo en ontario acá trudeau está cómoda
ahora está mucho más asegurado en
ontario se va a dar por por además por
el número de diputados más grandes mucho
más grandes el número de que otras
provincias canadienses y queremos de
jacques mixing jacques meet in del
partido de nuevo muy interesante se
defendió muy bien en francés tiene
políticas bien progresistas en algunas
coincidía construido también lo que lo
que dice
chantal es ver es que cuidado porque si
va puede causar una sorpresa cuando
discuta y debata en su lengua que es el
inglés porque en francés se defendió muy
bien defendió las ideas de su partido
que es un partido progresista también
entonces ese sí yo creo que bueno acá no
tiene muchas posibilidades
ya hubo una ola naranja que fue con el
otro líder y fue en las elecciones
anteriores no del 15 sino anteriormente
entonces eran atraerle están tenían
muchas más no hay que olvidarse además
que salía dejaba la piel del su cargo
harper que venía con una política de
derecha en canadá entonces
entonces bueno yo había escuchado es que
se fue o fue casi casi una defensa
constante de todos no hubo no hubo como
necesidad de la propuesta si no fue
defenderse defenderse defenderse
continuamente que eso fue el leitmotiv
de esta primera ganador y un perdedor de
lo que ella dice que es el partido
conservador en este caso pero ganadores
no hubo lo que si también a ella le
sorprendió un poco fue la performance de
crudo y lo que es lo que me llamó la
atención cuando dijo chantal everest que
crudo se impuso a sí mismo estar todos
los miércoles de cada semana en el
parlamento para responder a todas las
preguntas ustedes vieron cómo funciona
la sesión todos ahí hacen preguntas y el
primer ministro contesta no está
obligado de presentarse pero es como que
lo estuvo haciendo y esa práctica que él
desarrolló en el parlamento le ayudó
porque dice su oratoria nunca fue un
punto fuerte para todo en este momento
se está está demostrando que eso les
sirve para enfrentar a otros
contrincantes algunas personas dijeron
piensan que todo piensa en inglés y
traduce al francés al hablar entonces
que a veces un poco se le quedan yo cola
pero en general
también aunque tal vez últimamente en
inglés supongo que vive más en inglés de
cualquier manera y maestro es una lengua
mayoritaria en canadá y se pasea por
todo el país entonces supongo que hay
hoy tenemos muy poco tiempo para hablar
de nuestros temas tenemos que parar de
la campaña pero vamos a seguir hablando
como dijiste pues hay próximos debates
que se vienen y vamos a cubrir el debate
en inglés en francés entonces un poco
iba a ser definitoria las elecciones son
el 21 de octubre entonces ya no queda
nada ya no queda nada cuando son en
argentina qué día es que nos diga nada
hablemos de carne carne
bueno esto viene este artículo que salió
hace un par de días viene a desmitificar
oa ponerse en contra de las leyes que ya
están aprobadas en canadá y eeuu por
ejemplo sobre el tema del consumo de
carne porque durante los últimos 10 años
ha habido un
y muy grande en contra del consumo de
carne y esto indicaba que las cantidades
de carne que uno come aparte de un tema
que ellos se encargaron de decir que no
habían tocado que es el del medio
ambiente pero que el consumo de carne
produce cáncer el consumo de carnes
procesadas aumenta en un 12% si no me
equivoco las posibilidades del cáncer
colorrectal o sea es complicado y es
complicado que venga un estudio de gran
envergadura a decir no es verdad en
realidad tampoco dijeron que no es
verdad dijeron que eran de cualquier
manera que la moderación en su justa
medida es lo que corresponde que no
dicen comer más carne dice no cambiar la
dieta y se ha alzado la foto es en este
año así que bueno el tema es justamente
que no es que estén promocionando comer
carne comer carne que hace bien o sea
todo en su justa medida lo que ellos
recomiendan
no cambiar la dieta por menos carne
porque eso fue lo que pasó el año pasado
el gobierno canadiense emitió la
alimentaria y la carne es casi nada
de las carnes rojas así que no lean el
artículo es bastante interesante
también con el vino el alcohol bises
vino yo siempre me acuerdo rápidamente
de la película big size me' donde este
hombre estuvo durante un mes comiendo el
producto mal donde mcdonald's desayuno
almuerzo merienda y cena terminó
destruido pobrecito su organismo no lo
somos aguantaba más pero piensen comer
carne todo el día todos los días piense
en comer pasta todo el día todos los
días
no comer ninguna proteína solamente
plantas todo el día el cuerpo necesita
otras cosas aparte ahí con la carne
porque no nos queda tiempo para las
cosas leonora sí bueno entonces como
vimos al principio
mes de octubre que se inició esta semana
es el gran festejo durante 30 días en
montreal estamos hablando precisamente
acá del 1 al 30 donde se festeja por
primera vez el mes de la herencia
latinoamericana fue la inauguración este
primero estuvo como ya lo dijimos
la alcaldesa de montreal y muchísima
gente una mesa de trabajo que coordinó
hay trabajo para que esto sea de una
realidad no aquí en montreal y que ya
pues el envión y ya fue dado y se piensa
que por supuesto va a seguir creciendo
este mes se pueden encontrar muchísimos
hay muchas actividades culturales como
dijiste bien sociales y un poco la idea
y yo hice tres entrevistas diferentes
esta última ya tiene que ver un poco más
con la contribución socioeconómica
justamente de la comunidad
latinoamericana de montreal conversamos
con héctor de giraldo que él es el
director general de la cámara de
comercio latinoamericana de quebec y él
explicaba un poco el mandato antes que
nada de esta cámara decía que tenía fue
creado en 2010
en 2007 y tenía como dos objetivos bien
concretos uno que la cámara acompaña a
las misiones comerciales de quebec hacia
américa latina y los que vienen de
américa latina' acá la cámara está
presente siempre ayudando al gobierno
canadiense y por otro lado también es
colaborar con los profesionales aquí en
quebec ayudándoles en sus demás en sus
en su trayectoria atrás cuando llegan
acá facilitándole la información en fin
hay una serie de cosas cuando uno emigra
quebec canadá que necesita pues
información entonces les apoyan
totalmente entonces esto es un poco lo
que la cámara de comercio está
presentando también este mes aquí en la
ciudad de montreal invitan a todos los
materiales a interesarse en lo que
finalmente en todas estas contribuciones
que hace la comunidad latinoamericana
aquí en montreal a islas y demos hay
actos culturales presentaciones hay un
baile que viene maestros del baile
folclórico que es una cumbre que se
llama
desde varios países en este momento en
ese marco entonces la serie de
reportajes las encontramos entonces
sobre esto si lo encontramos en el sitio
y la primera por ejemplo en el que fue
conversación con víctor armónica es un
sociólogo acá muy conocido donde da un
marco explicativo a cómo se da este mes-
latinoamericano con cifras porque les
conoce muy bien la evolución en número
también de las comunidades de américa
latina y bueno nomás nos queda muy
poquito tiempo les cuento que pablo está
presentando un reportaje sobre el
vigésimo primer congreso de estudios
inuit que se está llevando a cabo aquí
en la ciudad de montreal o sea de todas
las comunidades del norte de canadá
entonces si quieren escuchar la
entrevista con una de sus invitadas que
justamente viene de nunavut del gran
lejano norte canadiense que viene a
contar su historia su nombre es a lucky
cottier y es presidenta de un organismo
que defiende los defiende los derechos
de los inuit en el lejano norte claro
habla castellano
muy interesante y por mi parte yo les
presento una entrevista que tuve con un
joven jugador de béisbol que dice a
quien que ve aquí en canadá y en quebec
donde hay béisbol hay latinoamericanos
no todos latinoamericanos porque los
sudamericanos me decía leonardo no
juegan es mar centroamericano y un poco
no sé colombia y vea claro caribe
también entonces yo entrevisté a
fernando fernández beltrán es un joven
jugador de béisbol como decía él ha
tenido una trayectoria desde muy
chiquito en el béisbol le encanta este
deporte fue de hecho seleccionado por
los filis de filadelfia y bueno entonces
escuche la entrevista con él porque muy
interesante y ya nos tenemos que ir
antes de elecciones en argentina 27 de
octubre el islanders william en alarcón
nos dicen la fecha y dice miriam el
debate es el 13 de octubre santa fe el
20 de octubre - a la que interesante muy
bien es tarea
entonces se nos acaba rápidamente
asistencia
muchas gracias que nos acaba el tiempo
estén ahí la próxima semana tenemos como
les decía más información sobre el agua
y electoralista
[Música]
e
ah
a mí
[Música]